allez marine royale
et
g
[Applaudissements]
je suis là il faut je pisse en génie
alors attention
salez marie marie s'infiltre est en
place elle va partir avec 10 secondes
d'avancé sur alizé lim championne de
tennis
alizé elles courent m'arrive appartient
avec 10 secondes d'avancé sur alice
dialyse et c'est une vraie championne
c'est une grande championne de tennis
je suis fan d'alizée alizé elles courent
avec mathilde andraud ce soir record de
france de l'an chez diageo pour pour
l'association prendre un enfant par la
main ce sera ce soir dans la course des
champions sur france 2 pour le moment
alizée tu partiras avec dix secondes de
retard sur marie simard y arrive à
franchir la ligne d'arrivée avant
qu'alizé ne la rattrape vont tous les
chroniqueurs
je vous le dis seront payés double oui
dans le cas inverse
tous les chroniqueurs ne seront pas pays
non halal à la max pour toi comment
c'est normal que tu es mac le loser donc
forcément c'est une histoire de ta vie
elle a des vrais l'attention
mais attention à la 5è l'ex mari tu pars
avec dix secondes avant ce top c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
l'année oui
la sauce bien bien de la cible
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
habitué à les jeter ma vie je t'ai je me
fous de savoir qui m'a dit si tu es la
plus belle elle santé régine son avance